[Music]
my speech
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States and the president of
the United Mexican states
thank you
this evening we are honored to welcome
president Lopez Obrador the entire
Mexican delegation and many
distinguished guests to a White House
working dinner we've been working all
day and we'll be working for a little
while longer but it's an honor to have
you in the White House tonight's
gathering follows a productive day of
meetings and concludes an exceptional
visit in which we made tremendous
strides on behalf of our countries -
your great president I would just like
to say that it's been a profound
privilege to have you with us today and
it's a profound privilege to have you as
my friend we've had a great relationship
right from the beginning and I think
that maybe was against all odds a lot of
people were betting against it but
they've learned not to bet against this
I suspect I know they've learned that in
Mexico the people of Mexico the United
States had joined together by shared
values shared faith and shared future on
this beautiful continent we're both
proud sovereign nations built over
generations by the sweat sacrifice and
devotion of hard-working people who love
their country and who give everything
they have to create a better life for
their beautiful children in the United
States the extraordinary contributions
of mexican-americans are felt at every
industry every community and every facet
of our nation from art to Commerce to
science to medicine the Mexican people
are incredible they upheld our highest
values God family and country they
launched small businesses propel
industries and they serve heroically in
police departments and in our great
military as we gather tonight we reflect
on all that our two people have
accomplished together over the span of
many generations and we embrace the
incredible opportunities
that lay ahead we reach blessed with a
vast land that touches both of the
world's great oceans extraordinary
natural resources and above all were
blessed with some of the most spirited
adventurous
determined and talented people on the
face of the earth it's all about the
people
mr. president I'm certain that together
we can unlock a future of even greater
potential for our children prosperity
for our people safety for our citizens
and pride for our countries with today's
visit I've never been more confident
that the future of this precious
relationship and the destiny of this
majestic continent will never be in
better hands and never had a better
future
once again I want to thank you and all
of your representatives for being here
today it's a great honor it's a great
honor to be with you thank you very much
and now like to invite president Lopez
Obrador
to say a few words on behalf of the
incredible people of Mexico thank you
[Applause]
amigas amigas friends podría gentlemen
gravy I am going to be say D CK people
say that y know you very good implement
the window twice as good
Padilla so Louis he'd I could only say I
the choice everything said Louis puesto
by President Donald Trump
so most we are countries so much we are
people's neighbors hermanos brothers and
sisters we want to make good
relationship economic trade commercial
levels socially and culturally as well
that's the purpose as I said already
said earlier today commune so this is
the beginning of a new stage the most
model we have signed a new free trade
agreement yes Canada the United States
and Mexico we are going to strengthen
the economy the economy our region North
America you see a purpose fundamental
which is fundamental a fundamental of
course very good nice habit endorsed by
all three countries is the disagreement
Solomon has two new elements I do them
that help integrate the regions and 210
she ate first of all it said sports that
merchandise produced in our region
America regional content this is it that
is we're talking about any type of a
consumer product it does have to have
something produced in Canada Mexico and
the United States not really meant to
the other element I mean that I delecia
fundamental end of is a justice is
guaranteeing better salaries better
labor conditions a spice of all three
countries its own awesome
in the previous agreement that's why we
are just so happy the White House the
ceremony the bingo Tom being I also come
here I was invited to by my friend
resident on Yahoo they accompany to
preside businessman from Mexico
besides the staccato outstanding
business men and women solo not only
thing is they invest in treaties they
generate jobs but also because they they
have a social dimension stamping son
they are thinking not only humiliating
revenues and profits but also things to
go well for all of us for all of us to
define for people to also do well that's
why we are so appreciative of this
reception and the forecasts failed
we're not fighting we are friends and we
shall continue being friends thank you
very much
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much mr. president dr. Brooks says
we don't know how kovat impacts children
how can you say it's safe to send them
back to school
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
would you recommend that people download
that up on their phones tonight tomorrow
anytime currently only if you want your
private information in the hands of the
Chinese Communist Party